president Trump meets with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un we have
comprehensive coverage I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man is our coverage going to be
comprehensive today we are going to do
this thing soup-to-nuts we are going to
go through everything there is to go
through about the North Korean meeting
about President Trump hanging out with
Kim jong-un everything from their
personal relationship to the actual
statement that they signed together
first let's come make a couple
announcements so today 7:00 p.m. Eastern
we are doing a Father's Day special in
honor a Father's Day which makes sense
since the Father's Day special day Lee
Weyer god-king Jeremy boring is hosting
a roundtable discussion with me Andrew
Clavin Michael Mills for special guests
Alfonzo Rachel and Nick Searcy to
discuss the role of fatherhood in our
society I believe everyone there has
actually had children except for Knowles
will sit there uselessly as per our
usual arrangement we'll be
live-streaming on Facebook and YouTube
if you're a daily wire subscriber go to
daily where com submit live questions to
watch which will be monitored by Alicia
Kraus we will see you this afternoon
okay well as I say I want to get to
everything having to do with this
Kim Trump meetup I know that some people
are upset with me because I am skeptical
of the Kim Trump meetup I will explain
why in full color in full comprehensive
detail in just a second first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at the
u.s. CCA so gumlover Second Amendment
fans the clock is ticking how would you
like to hit the range tomorrow with a
brand new gun well pretty much
guaranteed you would since you like guns
the u.s. CCI wants to make that dream
come true for you they are here to help
train and protect responsible gun owners
like you and like me and right now
they're giving away free guns every
single day so you got to check them out
they're giving away a different gun
every single day at all and soon just go
to defend my family now calm to get
entered right away you can get up to 17
chances to win your gun daily it could
be 17 Kimber 17 Glock 17 new Springfield
all you have to do is go to defend my
family now calm to reveal which gun you
could be taking home today this all ends
soon
today's gun disappears at midnight today
so don't put this off don't miss your
chance right now you could win a new gun
every single day of the week just go to
defend my family now calm right now for
your free entry to win again that is
defend my family now calm us eca does
wonderful work providing you the
materials you need to be a better gun
owner and how you can keep yourself
safer I can protect yourself in case you
actually do have to use a weapon USC CH
does wonderful work check them out to
defend my family now calm and you also
get your 17 chances to win your gun
daily defend my family now calm okay
so biggest news ever some big news of
the day of course is that President
Trump goes over to Singapore and he
meets with Kim Jong Lou
now I want to begin with this kim
jeong-hoon is the world's worst dictator
he's a piece of human debris he is
garbage okay he has killed his uncle his
ex-girlfriend his brother-in-law
I believe he's killed all those people
within the last couple of years he held
his uncle at an airport using VX nerve
gas he has 25 million people living in
his slave state
he has 200,000 people living in his
gulags he is just sheer garbage and he
is generation number three of sheer
garbage in the Kim family a North Korean
defector talks a little bit on
television yesterday about the people in
North Korea in the fact they don't even
know that they're slaves because they've
never seen the outside world in order to
understand how horrible North Korea is
you have to understand that at night
when you take a photograph from space of
North Korea versus South Korea South
Korea is all lit up like a Christmas
tree and North Korea there's one light
and is it Kim Jong Un's Palace
legitimately hey here is what a defector
from North Korea said about North Korea
how bad was it in North Korea when you
were there it's hard to say because I
mean I thought like I never knew my
country was isolating people in North
Korea they don't know that they are
slaves that's why you know if we don't
know you are slaves how do you demand to
be free okay so bottom line is that this
is a slave state it is run by one of the
world's most evil families and the
world's most evil human being at this
point in time now the reason I point
this out is because people are treating
the summit with a bit of frivolity
they're treating it as a giant
celebration a coming-out party for kim
jeong-hoon and that it's completely
inappropriate the only reason that we're
meeting with kim jeong-hoon is because
he's been testing his nuclear weapons
and because his family has been pursuing
nuclear weapons and lying about it to
the west over and over and over again
unless we forget these lies have been
continuous and repeated okay the Kim
family has lied no less than eight times
since 1992 to the American government
about denuclearization eight times so
before everybody gets on their high
horse about all Trump and finally got
them to promise denuclearization they
have promised you nuclearization more
often than as many nights as there are
Konica he has promised he nuclearization
I mean he has promised you
nuclearization essentially every other
year the family has every other year
since 1992 and we're supposed to pretend
that his current promise means something
well Trump tweeted in the run-up to the
meeting that critics were were selling
him short he said the fact that I'm
having a meeting is a major loss for the
USA the haters and looters losers we
have our hostages testing research and
all missile launches has stopped and
these pundits who have called me wrong
from the beginning have nothing
they can say we will be fine okay just
to point out here yes we got some
hostages back so did Barack Obama in
2014 that is just historical fact as far
as testing and research and missile
launches have stopped we have no way to
verify whether researchers stopped
testing has stopped at the nuclear
mountain because they imploded their own
nuclear mountain and their missile
launches have stopped because they don't
want to set off president Trump in the
run-up to the meeting right that's
that's the idea here and President Trump
then continues and he says meetings
between staffs and representatives are
going well and quickly but in the end
that doesn't matter we will all know
soon whether or not a real deal unlike
those of the past can happen the truth
is usually a president of the United
States does not get together with a
foreign adversary to sign an agreement
until there's an agreement to be signed
until there's something real and decent
and long-lasting and verifiable to be
signed but the goal of these
negotiations is cvid okay complete
verifiable irreversible denuclearization
or dismantlement okay CVID
they're not really even talking about
that right now they're not really even
talking about that this was the big
question was President Trump going to be
handing kim jeong-hoon a public
relations victory by going going over
and hanging out with him or was he gonna
get some serious concessions now we
don't know the answer to that yet and
this is my note of caution we don't know
yet so what you're hearing from a lot of
folks on the right is triumph Nobel
Prize everything great has already
happened nothing great has happened in
fact right now the ledger is stacked in
favor of Kim jong-un because we just
handed them a massive PR victory we'll
go through the PR victory and all the
mistakes that were made over the last 36
hours and handing them a PR victory now
all those mistakes turn to gold
if Kim jong-un actually wants to
denuclearize so if the White House knows
something that we don't if the White
House actually has some sort of
verifiable regime of dismantlement
coming then this is the greatest move of
all time if they don't then it's a
debacle okay there really is no
in-between there's no in-between
position where Trump goes over there and
makes nice and plays kissy face with Kim
Jong hoon and doesn't get anything out
of him where it's not a debacle and on
the other hand if he gets what he wants
out of kim jeong-hoon
then obviously everything is justified
but right now everybody is jumping to
their various positions you got folks on
the right and they are jumping to the
position that Donald Trump has done
something masterful to masterstroke its
genius its mega Magna 3d underwater
chest upside down right and how do we
know that well because Trump's doing it
right if Obama has done the same thing
we would have gone nuts
but if Obama had gone over to Singapore
and hung out
kim jeong-hoon and stacked the American
flag alongside the flag of North Korea
we would have gone crazy because the
flag of North Korea is the modern-day
equivalent of the swastika they imagined
that Kim Jong Lunas Hitler and you
understand a little bit better why it
might not be a great idea to have all
these photo ops with a guy without
receiving any sort of serious
concessions in the first place so on the
right they're jumping to everything is
great everything's gonna be fine
no downside all terrific and on the Left
they're jumping too this is the worst
thing that has ever happened in the
history of the world the same people who
are insuring Obama for signing the
world's worst nuclear deal with Iran are
now saying the president Trump has done
something terrible by meeting with Kim
Jong hoon
even though the real concessions made at
this meeting are not particularly strong
right he didn't actually commit to
virtually anything he given to a few
things none of them are good but we
don't know yet yeah I spent I say a lot
on the show I spend a lot of time on my
show saying let's wait for the evidence
to come in and there's another case
where I'm gonna say let's wait for the
evidence to come in but we can say that
President Trump gave up something very
serious in these in this in this
photo-op he gave up the idea that
America as the freest country on the
face of the planet and most powerful
country on the face of the planet has
the capacity to talk down to Kim Jong we
should be talking down to him he's a
tin-pot dictator piece of crap he's a
horrible human being
been legitimizing him and pretending
that he's a normal person and that this
is a normal regime and then we gotta
have normal relations with this normal
regime without any serious concessions
being made I don't know why the
president says that I honestly don't I
don't know why this wasn't done from
lower level negotiators I don't know why
this wasn't done through Mike Pompeo I
don't know why this wasn't done through
the CIA there are plenty of ways to
negotiate these deals having the
president show up for a nice back rub
with Kim jong-un doesn't seem to me like
like a worthwhile cause now you have to
understand the level of reality TV that
was involved in this from the very start
you have you have Dennis Rodman on TV
crying so Dennis Rodman showed up in
Singapore wearing to make America great
again hat
this is nutcase okay he's been going
over to to North Korea for years back in
2014 a guy named Donald Trump tweeted
that he never would have said the
dominant that Dennis Rodman should go
over to North Korea and hang out with
Kim jong-un it's why he's glad he fired
him from Celebrity Apprentice now Dennis
Rodman is actually at this event and
then he starts crying on TV while
talking about how he is sponsored by
some sort of pot Bitcoin company
over the ductless I was sitting up
protecting everything and I believe it
on Korea and when I went home I can't go
home I couldn't go home for 30 days and
could hope but I kept my head up high
brother I knew things gonna change I
knew it I was the only one I never had
no one to hear me I didn't know what had
to see me but I took those bullets I
took all that I took everything everyone
came at me and I'm still standing today
is a great day for everybody SATA for
everything it's a great day and he said
he's standing there talking about pot
coin calm and Chris Cuomo humoring him
okay when Dennis Rodman says it's a
great day that doesn't necessarily mean
it's a great day it could just mean that
he took LSD like we just don't know it's
Dennis Rodman okay so all of this
happens Kim jong-un and Donald Trump
walk out and here is the historic moment
everybody says it's historic they always
say historic as the historic is good
historic just means historic meaning
that it makes history but lots of things
were historic Neville Chamberlain was
historic and so was so as opening China
right lots of things are historic here's
what it looked like when President Trump
met with Kim jong-un for the first time
as we see President Trump getting
prepared to walk to center stage and
there it is the first handshake between
the United States President positive
right now you can see the danger in in
this in this image okay and the image is
of course a bunch of American flags
stacked up against a bunch of North
Korean flags if those were swastikas
everybody would understand this
okay symbolism matters and I guess we
play Kim jong-un as though he is some
sort of joke is that he's just a fat boy
who's a joke okay there's an element of
that but the guy also happens to be a
mass murderer like an actual mass
murderer so in any case President Trump
says that he is happy to get the guy to
the table and then he says that he felt
foolish with doing the fire and fury
rhetoric but he had to do it he told
this to Sean Hannity he says that you
know that's the way that you get Kim
jong-un to the table in the first place
I think without the rhetoric we wouldn't
have been here I really believe that you
know we did sanctions and all of the
things that you would do but I think
without the rhetoric you know other
administration's I don't want to get
specific on that but they had a policy
of silence if they said something very
bad
very threatening and horrible just don't
answer that's not the answer that's not
what you have to do okay so I agree with
president Trump's harsh rhetoric I agree
with President Trump harsh rhetoric with
regard to kim jeong-hoon I don't think
that it was his harsh rhetoric that
brought Kim jong-un to the table I think
that was the South Korean administration
which has been extraordinarily open
toward kim jong hoon and basically
brokered this deal so I like the harsh
rhetoric I have no problem with the fire
and fury rhetoric with regard to Kim
jong-un it doesn't bother me one iota in
fact I'd like more of that more of the
harsh Trump rhetoric less of the kissy
kissy face for me because I just I'm not
a big fan of how this went so in just a
second I'm going to explain to you what
exactly went down in this deal because I
have the document in front of me what
exactly was signed and why it basically
is a giant nothing burger for the moment
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsor is over at puppy spots so
welcoming a puppy into your home is is
incredibly rewarding I know that my
sister is a puppy owner she loves her
dog I mean loves her dog and for folks
who have a dog it really makes an
enormous difference in their lives
obviously these these puppies become
their best friends and this is why you
want to go to a place where you know the
puppies have been treated well or you
know that every puppy has been vetted
and that's what puppy spot com is for
it's a trusted service connecting the
nation's top breeders to caring
responsible individuals and families it
shouldn't be a mystery or a compromise
when you when you get a puppy puppy spot
is more than a service they're actually
advocates they have 200 plus dog loving
team members who ensure that only the
highest level of licensed breeders can
enter their exclusive breeder community
and you can view thousands of puppies
from golden retrievers to your Kisa
labradoodles and their puppy concierge
service will help find the right breed
for you it makes it absolutely
convenience and easy to find your new
best friend their industry leading
health guarantee means that your puppies
vaccinations are up to date as well
which is awesome and all of the puppies
receiving nose-to-tail health exam from
a licensed vet before they are brought
safely home to you so go to puppy
spot.com /ban that's puppy spot.com
slash bend and for a limited time i'll
Ben Shapiro show listeners receive
access to the puppy spot VIP program
discounts on everything you need for
your new puppy from food to walking
services you get that awesome deal when
you go to puppy spot com / Bend for that
special offer again puppy spot com / Ben
get your new best friend the best way
puppy spot com / then go check it out
all right so what actually was in this
this deal between new best friends
president Trump and kim jeong-hoon so
here is what the deal says it says
Donald Trump of the United States of
America and chairman kim jeong-hoon of
the state affairs Commission of the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
held first historic summit in Singapore
on June 12th 2018
president Trump and chairman kim
jeong-hoon conducted a comprehensive
in-depth and sincere exchange of
opinions on the issues related to the
establishment of new u.s. DPRK relations
and the building of a lasting and robust
peace regime on the Korean Peninsula
president Trump committed to provide
security guarantees to DPRK and chairman
Kim jong-un reaffirmed his firm an
unwavering commitment to complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
let's stop there for just a second okay
what that means is that President Trump
made commitments that he would not
actually involve the United States in
joint military drills with the South
Koreans and Kim jong-un said I'm gonna
do the same thing my dad and my granddad
promise and I'm gonna lie about it
that's not a promising start now listen
I know maybe there's more to come maybe
there's more to come but I need to see
the evidence there's more to come before
I start getting excited about its deal
that basically is weaker than prior
deals in fact is that the joint
comprehensive framework that was come up
with in 2005-2006 is stronger than this
deal convinced that the establishment of
new u.s. DPRK relations will contribute
to the peace and prosperity of the
Korean Peninsula and of the world and
recognizing the mutual conference
building can promote the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
president Trump and Kim jong-un state
the following and here we get to the
actual four basic principles of the deal
principle one the US and the DPRK commit
to establish new u.s. DPRK relations in
accordance with the desire of the
peoples of the two countries for peace
and prosperity as someone doesn't mean
anything to the United States and the
DPRK will join their efforts to build a
lasting and stable peace regime on the
Korean Peninsula okay again that doesn't
mean anything
three reaffirming the April 27 2018
Panama and John declaration the DPRK
commits to work toward complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
denuclearization is actually a weaker
promise and has been made in Prior
agreements and then for the United
States and zpr can commit to recovering
pio wmia remains including the immediate
immediate repatriation of those already
identified and then there's a bunch of
language about how much fun they had
together there's nothing new here and
one that Trump has been pumping the
hardest is the PIO wmia language the
suggestion that we're gonna bring home
the remains of all these POWs in Mis
that's great except that this has been a
Korean promise for legitimately 30 years
Korean officials have been promising
between to do this since the 1980s
between 1996 and 2005 u.s. North Korean
search teams conducted 33 joint recovery
operations and recovered 229 sets of
American remains that program was
actually discontinued for a time because
North Korea insisted we pay them bribes
in order so that we could gather the
bones of the American dead some
Americans were referring to this as
bones for bucks weary continued it in
2011 and then we stopped again in 2016
so the deal itself is no great shakes so
what that means is that the only way for
this to be a success is if it is a first
step now in order for it to be as
success as a first step two things have
to happen Trump can't give up too much
upfront and second there must be an
actual thing that we get on the back end
now I want to talk about what Trump gave
up here in just a second so let's begin
President Trump does this press
conference last night he's obviously
very pleased with himself he's obviously
very excited because this is the
historic moment
it's the moment the world came together
it's his nobel-prize-winning moment
because he went and just as Nixon went
to China Trump went in Singapore okay so
Trump starts off and this is one of the
problems so the big wins that President
Trump handed the North Koreans were a
couple fold there a few of them so first
off there was the the so first off there
was the Trump praise for Kim Jong hoon
okay and there there was plenty of it so
it begins
with president from talking about how
talented Kim Jong hoon is now I
understand this is from stick I get it
like I understand President Trump is
trying to build relations what are you
gonna go over there and yell at him that
he's a dictator mass murderer no but you
also don't have to say that he's the
world's most wonderful guy I understand
again this is Trump stick he says this
about everyone during first meets them
but it's not good and just the same way
it was stupid when President Bush said
that he looked into Putin's eyes and he
saw his soul I think this is idiotic
here's President Trump saying that Kim
Jong moon is very talented he said this
sort of nonsense before well he is very
talented anybody that takes over a
situation like he did at 26 years of age
and is able to run it and run it tough I
don't say it was nice or I don't say
anything about it he run it very few
people at that age you can take one out
of 10,000 probably couldn't do it okay
he's a dictator who legitimately murders
political dissidents that's not the
language the presidents of the United
that shameful language the presidents of
the United States should not be using
that language about one of the most evil
people on planet earth I don't care
whether it's
obama or bush or Clinton or Trump that's
not the language you use with kim
jeong-hoon and then President Trump goes
further he actually starts talking about
all of the concessions he would like to
make to Kim jong-un some will
materialize some will not but none of
this none of the signals strength to
come jong-un it actually signals
weakness to Kim jong-un at some point I
have to be honest and I used to say this
during my campaign as you know probably
better than most I want to get our
soldiers out I want to bring our
soldiers back home we have right now
32,000 soldiers in South Korea and I'd
like to be able to bring them back home
but that's not part of the equation
right now at some point I hope it will
be but not right now we will be stopping
the war games which will save us a
tremendous amount of money unless and
until we see that the future negotiation
is not going along like it should okay
so so Trump's made some sort of
concessions here one of the concessions
is that we're going to hold off on joint
military exercises with South Koreans
this apparently surprised the South
Koreans he said that these exercises
were quote-unquote very provocative okay
that's the language that that Kim Jong
hoon probably said to Trump these are
provocative exercises they're not
provocative exercises they're joint
military exercises they're not meant to
provoke a response from North Korea
they're meant as a warning to North
Korea the president shouldn't be talking
in those terms about joint military
exercises and then he starts talking
again about how wonderful Kim jong-un is
he talks about how Kim jong-un really
wants to get something done I think he
wants to do things I think he wants to
you'd be very surprised very smart very
good negotiator wants to do the right
thing I believe it's a rough situation
over there there's no question about it
and we did discuss it today pretty
strongly I mean knowing what the main
purpose of what we were doing is Dino
king but discussed it in a pretty good
length we'll be doing something on it
it's it's rough it's rough in a lot of
places by the way not just there but
it's rough and we will continue that and
I think ultimately again brushing off
human rights abuses in North Korea as
it's rough in a lot of places it's it's
this is not a good look from the
presidents of the United States now the
reason I'm being critical is because
what President Trump is trying to do
here obviously is butter up kim
jeong-hoon like really butter him up the
idea here is we'll make Kim jong-un feel
so
about himself that he'll give up his
nuclear weapons I'm deeply skeptical kim
jeong-hoon falls for this but clearly
that's what Trump is trying to do to put
the best possible spin on it for Trump
that he doesn't like Kim jong-un but
he's trying to manipulate Kim jong-un
he's trying to butter him up I think the
most buttery thing that he said actually
was not during this press conference
we'll get back to the clips from the
press conference in just a second
it's clip 19 where he was with Greta Van
Susteren and apparently decided that we
were going to do an episode of the
dating game but oh but um but um here he
is describing his potential date kim
jeong-hoon really he's got a great
personality he's a you know funny guy
he's a very smart guy he's a great
negotiator
he loves his people not that I'm
surprised by that but he loves his
people and I think that we have a you
know the start of an amazing deal with
Anna Dean nuke North Korea it's going to
start immediately and a lot of other
things are happening
he loves his people don't you understand
he loves his people just like to serve
man right from from Twilight Zone
he they also the aliens loved their
people to eat them okay Kim jong-un has
kept his people in a state of abject
slavery for legitimately decades and he
loves his people how is that helpful how
is that helpful okay so if he butters
know again all of this is contingent on
something really big has to happen at
the other end if not this is the
President of the United States lying
town and playing dead for the worst
dictator on planet Earth we'll get to
more of President Trump statements on
all this plus the blowback in just a
second the media blowback is
hypocritical and I'll talk about that
but first I want to say thanks to our
sponsor is over at policy genius if you
have a car you have car insurance and if
you have a home you have home insurance
if you're alive you should have life
insurance because once you die it's too
late and then your family is screwed
right because then you didn't get all
the life insurance you needed and now
they're left without any money at all
that's why policy genius has made it
easy for you to search for life
insurance policy genius is the easy way
to compare life insurance online in just
five minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurance to find the best
policy for you and when you compare
quotes you save money it is that simple
in fact policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance and
placed over twenty billion dollars in
coverage they don't just make life
insurance easy they also committed
disability insurance from renter's
insurance and health insurance and if
you care about it they can cover it if
you've been putting off getting life
insurance there's no reason for you to
do that it's actually deeply
irresponsible i order you right now go
to policy genius right now and get life
insurance to make sure that your family
is taken care of go over to policy
genius calm it's the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance
I have life insurance my wife has life
insurance you two should have life
insurance and again they have not just
life insurance but disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance all the insurance you'll need
governor policy genius.com to get that
insurance and insure your family is
taken care of ok so back to president
Trump's press conference so president
Trump continues by talking about how he
and here President Trump is talking
about the media hypocrisy so a lot of
people are saying well why is this any
different than when Obama was trying to
make concessions to the Cubans of the
turanians and Trump rightly is saying
listen the deal that I'm cutting right
now isn't making more concessions than
anything Obama did and this is one of
the great ironies of this particular
political moment is that all the people
who thought that Obama was just terrible
for the Iran deal are cheering wildly
president Trump meeting with Kim jong-un
and massaging his back and all the
people who are really really angry and
President Trump for doing this on the
left were wildly ecstatic about
President Trump back massaging the
mullahs in Iran and then there are those
of us who say listen it's bad when Obama
back massage the mullahs and it's bad
when Trump back massages Kim Jong loon
is bad when Obama kisses the butt of
some of the worst people on earth and
it's bad when Trump does that as well
there'd better be some sort of payoff on
the other end here's Trump going after
the media however Jennifer when you look
at all of those things that we got and
when we got our hostages back I didn't
pay 1.8 billion in cash like the
hostages that came back from Iran which
was a disgraceful situation what took
place so we've gotten a lot so when I
hear somebody in the media say that
President Trump has agreed to meet like
it's not a big deal to meet I think we
should meet on a lot of different topics
not just this one and I really believe a
lot of great things can happen okay it
is a big deal to me it is a big deal to
mate okay it's a big deal to meet for
the North Koreans may not be a big deal
for Trump to me but it's the United
States he has the prestige and power of
the United States sitting behind him
granting meetings to some of the worst
people on earth is a bad idea there's a
reason that President Trump for example
hasn't been willing to meet with members
of the Muslim Brotherhood there's a
reason that he's not willing to meet
with the leadership of Iran everybody
understands this on an innate level
president Trump understands it too he's
brushing off the meeting is a big
nothing because nothing has happened yet
but that's exactly the point nothing has
happened yet so why are you meeting what
is the point of this meeting and when I
say that there's been triumphalism
surrounding his meeting I mean I
I mean coming from the Trump
administration so president Trump tweets
out this video he's 18 he tweets out
this video of a compilation of himself
meeting with kim jeong-hoon i'll
describe it to you and you can hear the
music underneath because all this
triumphal music is though something
great has been done again nothing great
has been done yet maybe something will
be done but so far all I've seen is the
President of the United States walking
arm-in-arm with one of the worst people
on planet Earth and then flattering him
as a wonderful smart guy yeah that's not
great to me I'm waiting for the great
part to come I understand that maybe
this is the setup well I need the
punchline before I start laughing
otherwise I'm just gonna be angry at the
setup cuz I don't like the setup very
much Trump though is touting the setup
as though this is some sort of big win
the problem with this video is that if
you cut it shot-for-shot with the same
music you could play it on Pyongyang TV
in favor of kim jeong-hoon here's what
the video sounds like so you can see
Trump walking into the venue and then
you see him shaking hands with kim jong
hoon and both of them smiling and
trumping very warm and the triumphal
music everything's just spectacular then
then walking along some sort of portico
together and then sitting together and
and Trump smiling at him and then and
then Mike Pompeo coming in and shaking
has a kinder than both of them very
smiling then sitting across the table
and the hopeful music Rises oh and then
they're both waving to the crowd come
gentlemen smiling they're walking
together in the gardens okay none of
this is useful the point of this meeting
is supposed to get kim jungeun to
understand do you actually need to make
concessions because if you don't make
concessions we're gonna kick the living
bleep out of you right that's what this
meeting was supposed to be not President
Trump going in there and making nice
that we can then claim that we've won
some sort of victory diplomacy is not a
victory diplomacy is a tactic just
because you are being diplomatic does
not mean that you did anything wonderful
it depends what's on the other end of
the diplomacy Obama did this routine -
this is my original complaint about
Trump meeting with Kim Jong hoon I said
it at the time go back and listen to the
tape I've been saying it for weeks
saying that you're gonna meet with
somebody makes the diplomacy the chief
goal the diplomacy is never the chief
goal now they're a bunch of people today
who are making the same argument that
Obama made about Iran well what would
you have him do you go to war with North
Korea no I wouldn't have them go to war
with North Korea I would have his lower
level negotiators making clear to the
North Koreans what the deal should be
and then when it's time for Trump to
actually
then he gets to walk in and sign a big
piece of paper but preliminary handing
the sort of legitimacy and kindness to
kim jeong-hoon
is not useful I mean speaking of
legitimacy and kindness your President
Trump has been saying for a long time
that one of the keys here is that he's
used very harsh language with regard to
North Korea that if North Korea violates
then we may have to use fire and fury
well yesterday he basically took fire
and fury off the table here as president
from talking about how if we went to war
30 million people would die which is
essentially taking military force off
the table effectively this is the press
conference they the quote beginning
Seoul Seoul has 28 million people think
of that and it's right next to the
border it's right next to the DMZ it's
right there I mean if this would have
happened I think you know I've heard Oh
a hundred thousand people I think you
could have lost 20 million people 30
million people this is really an honor
for me to be doing this because I think
you know potentially you could have lost
you know 30 40 50 million people the
city of Seoul one of the biggest cities
in the world is right next to the the
border okay so the fact that he's saying
this is effectively taking the option
off the table which is not a good idea
idea right mean there should be no
options off the table obviously and
president Trump's whole shtick here when
it comes to foreign policy is you never
give away your hand and maybe we'll hit
you with a club and maybe we'll give you
a carrot but you never give away your
hand here's President Trump tipping his
hand and that's not particularly smart
it's just it's it's not particularly
bright and I'm upset with him for having
done it obviously unless unless I keep
saying unless because we don't know what
the unless is so we have to hold off
judgment unless there's some sort of big
concession by the North Koreans and then
this this I thought was the funniest
part of the press conference so Trump
showed Kim a tape apparently I've seen
the tape now it's it's this highly
produced little tape with a big narrator
voice with with the big narrator going
Trump Kim can they make peace and then a
bunch of pictures of people playing
basketball and people dancing and
singing and then a bunch of pictures of
missiles and all this kind of stuff it's
pretty it's pretty amazing
but Trump talks about you know the tape
and what he showed Kim he says that was
a version of what hey I can that was a
version of what could happen what could
take place as an example they have great
beaches you see that whenever they're
exploding their cannons into the ocean
right boy look at that baby wouldn't
that make a great condo behind and I
explained I said you know instead of
doing that you could have the best
hotels in the world right there think of
it from a real estate perspective you
have South Korea you have China and they
own the land in the middle how bad is
that right it's great but I told him I
said you may not want to do what's there
you may want to do a smaller version of
it or you know and that could be
although I tell you what he he looked at
that tape he looked at that iPad and I'm
telling you they they they really
enjoyed it I believe here's the point
the United States does not have to
engage in a charm offensive with North
Korea were the most powerful country in
the history of the world by a factor of
10 there's legitimately no reason we
have to engage in a charm offensive when
we're telling a tin-pot dictatorship to
give up their nukes
the charm offensive stuff if it works
then I'm happy to say the president
Trump did something unprecedented and
massive and wonderful but if it doesn't
then all that happened is the President
of the United States made a tin-pot
dictator look like somebody who's
actually worth the time and I'm not
seeing that again you know President
Trump's language here has been I don't
think useful I think it's been
counterproductive again I'm willing to
withhold judgment I'm willing to
withhold judgment he he says that he is
ready to trust Kim jong-un this is the
third clip from from the ABC interview
of Stephanopoulos he says that he's done
a lot of deals and and I think that I
might be able to trust Kim jong-un again
not sure why I've done a lot of deals
with a lot of people and sometimes the
people that you most distrust turn out
to be the most honorable ones and the
people that you do trust they are not
the honorable ones so we are starting
from a very high plane we're starting
from a very good relationship this has
been a very big day in terms of the
world I think it's been maybe a lot of
people are saying it's just all historic
right and everybody's talking about how
historic it is historically good
historically bad we don't know yet we
don't know yet but I will say this the
media who are treating this with grave
skepticism I wish they treated the Iran
deal with the same grave skepticism and
conservatives who are treating this as
an unmitigated triumph I wish that they
had treated this the same way they
treated the Iran deal the deal is not a
deal until there is a deal okay this is
true of every deal in business and in
politics there's no serious deal that's
been made
all that's happened so far is that Trump
has offered an unrealistic tater ship on
planet Earth put their flag alongside
the flag of the United States you know
many Americans died to keep that North
Korean flag from flying over South Korea
50 thousand Americans died to keep that
flag from flying over South Korea that
means that we're gonna fly it alongside
the American flag they're damn well
better be a good reason and it can't
just be because Trump wants a photo-op
there has to be an actual good reason
and that means actual denuclearization I
hope that's what the Trump
administration has in its back pocket I
suspect that it is not from speaking to
many people with with knowledge of the
situation I suspect that it is not but
if it is then more power to them and all
this ends up being a coup it ends up
being the greatest thing ever and I pray
that it is
if not it ends up being a debacle and
Obama Essex debacle worse in in some
ways then then anything except for the
Iran deal on the Obama Ledger okay so I
want to talk about Bill Clinton and how
Bill Clinton continues to get away with
everything in just a second you're gonna
have to come over to Daley wire for that
though $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription to Daley where you get the
rest of the show live get the rest of
Clavin show live the rest of Knowles's
show live you can ask us live questions
when we do our Father's Day special this
evening and when you go over to the
Daily wire and submit your questions you
go to the conversation page you watch
the live stream and you can type your
questions into the daily Wired chat box
next Tuesday I am apparently doing an
episode of the conversation which as you
can see I am just thrilled about which
means I get to sit here with you for an
additional hour and answer all of your
questions again all you have to do is
submit your questions into the chat box
and Alicia will grab them and read them
out loud and then we will answer them
and it will make your life that much
better you are able to ask those
questions with the subscription annual
subscription comes along with this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
they left his tears hot or cold tumblr
and you'll enjoy it
you'll love it okay also please
subscribe and leave this review at
YouTube and at iTunes as well subscribe
and leave this review also so that
you're updated whenever we have a Sunday
special that comes out we have a lot of
great material comes out a regular basis
and we could not make this show we could
not bring you objective truth as well as
opinion on this show without without
your help so we really appreciate it we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile President Clinton continues
to get away with everything he made some
comments the other day that went largely
unremarked upon by mainstream media he
said in an interview that sexual
misconduct norms have changed how have
they changed President Clinton explained
I in general I think it's a good thing
yes I think it's a good thing that we we
should all have higher standards
I think the norms have really changed in
terms of what you can do to somebody
against their will how much you can
crowd their space make them miserable
work you don't have to physically
assault somebody to make them you know
uncomfortable at work or at home or and
their other just walking around ok so um
the standards have changed about how
much you can do with somebody against
their consent yeah I love that the
follow-up question here is not well what
was the standard with wanita Broderick
what was the standard with Paula Jones
what was the stander with Kathleen
Willey my favorite part of all these
interviews with Bill Clinton is the
James Patterson the best-selling author
maybe of all time is sitting next to him
just looking egregiously uncomfortable
just looking like he wants to crawl into
a hole and die it's pretty spectacular
but Bill Clinton again still a respected
voice on the left and then we wonder why
people don't take the media seriously we
wonder why wouldn't media ask critical
questions about North Korea everybody
blows them off maybe it's because
they're a bunch of hypocrites maybe it's
because they're ridiculous now speaking
of ridiculous this story is amazing so
Jack Dorsey is the head of Twitter he
was he tweeted out that he had ordered a
bag of sandwiches from chick-fil-a so he
tweeted out boost chick-fil-a and then
it showed a image of how much money he
has spent at chick-fil-a he spent like
30 bucks at chick-fil-a and then he was
called on it by Soledad O'Brien who
immediately said this is an interesting
company to boost during Pride Month Jack
because it's Gay Pride Month this month
which if you didn't if you didn't know
congratulations it's Gay Pride Month and
then Jack responded you're right
completely forgot about their background
he never should have shopped at
chick-fil-a during Gay Pride Month it's
basically like gay Ramadan
now it's during this month you mustn't
we're gonna fast from all of the
Christian owned companies during gay
Ramadan Gay Pride Month no one no one
must ever shop from chick-fil-a a
company that has never discriminated
against homosexuals in any way but whose
owners are against same-sex marriage
anybody who Shops at chick-fil-a is
violating the precepts of Gay Pride
Month because the Gay Pride jihadis are
gonna come after you and insist that you
do repentance very very important stuff
from Soledad O'Brien the best part of
this is that Soledad O'Brien did an
event in 2012 sponsored by chick-fil-a
so she was happy to take the cash from
chick-fil-a but now she's very upset the
Gay Pride Month it's sanctity it's
sanctity has been violated by the evil
that is tweeting out that you shop to
check the way to get a sandwich and then
people wonder why people voted for
president Trump you know as critical as
I am of President Trump from time to
time the fact is that the left does
nothing but push people into president
Trump's camp with social cultural more
issues like this you know I like a lot
of president Trump's policy I don't like
a lot of President Trump's rhetoric some
of the things President Trump does like
this North Korean summit I think are
foolhardy and problematic but when you
have an entire group of people who
insist that I cannot shop at the chicken
sandwich shop of my choosing because
that might offend homosexual people for
no reason at all it sort of makes me
think maybe I'll just vote for the guy
who's not doing that maybe I'll vote for
the guy who doesn't take that stuff
particularly seriously pretty amazing
stuff there from from Jack Dorsey I love
the Jack Dorsey has to acknowledge that
so it took Jack Dorsey like months and
months and months to punish Louis
Farrakhan by taking away his
verification on Twitter he shouldn't
have taken away his verification he
shouldn't ban him either I think it's
good Liu's Farrakhan is out there he
reminds us how scummy human beings can
be he's just piece of garbage but that
said Jack Dorsey has been a number of
people from Twitter but not Louis
Farrakhan so he still hasn't been Lewis
Farrakhan but he's never gonna shop at
chick-fil-a during Gay Pride Ramadan so
that's that's very exciting stuff okay
meanwhile speaking of ridiculous stuff
the Tony Awards happened last night and
they were on Sunday night and they were
particularly replete with anti Trump
rhetoric foolishness so we talked about
this a little bit yesterday but Robert
DeNiro dropped an f-bomb on the air
he decided that to show what a hero he
was he was going to say F Trump in front
of a crowd of people who hate Trump
because that's really careless I mean
the approval rating for Trump in this
room is negative 37% like it's not even
that there is no approval rating I mean
it's 100% disapproval and and so he did
something really brave he went out there
and ripped Trump in front of all these
people at the Tony Awards
[Applause]
I'm gonna say one thing Trump
standing ovations
standing ovations set up Trump well you
know what and I love how they stand and
they cheer and he's and then he goes
like this he gives like the big two
fists up and he like pumps his fist as
though he's actually succeeded in making
Trump not president anymore that by
shouting F Trump Trump is no longer the
president it's in the Constitution if
Robert De Niro goes on stage and Chad
and shouts F Trump about you then that
means that we can we can safely remove
the president from office and then of
course Andrew Garfield got up the guy
from spider-man that not the not the new
one that's good the old one that's bad
he he got up and he started talking
about how everybody should abandon
everybody should basically bake cakes
for the gays if if they are asked to do
so for a gay wedding and such we are all
sacred and we all belong so let's just
bake a cake for everyone who wants a
cake to be baked
except for Christians Christians are not
sacred and they are not there they they
do not belong Christians do not belong
and as I proposed yesterday I believe
that Andrew Garfield should actually act
I will write a play about the Christian
Baker's who were discriminated against
by the Colorado Commission on civil
rights and Andrew Garfield can play the
lead he can play the Christian Baker and
I will raise the money to do that and he
should have to do that because he should
act for whoever whoever wants him to act
I mean it's a free market it's an open
open society he should I demand his
services and his services I shall have
Andrew Garfield's and then it got even
better of course this this actress from
a new a new musical about Harry Potter
I guess she says that President Trump
should not come to see the show he
should be banned from the show so Andrew
Garfield says that a Christian Baker
should have to service a same-sex
wedding but this actress says her name
is Noma du mezzo NE she says that Trump
should not be able to come to her play
so yeah there's no double standard here
at all should the president come see the
Harry Potter Harry Potter in the curse
child no thank you
anybody else yeah anybody else yes but
not him not him
so there's here's a question the
question is why is it that the Tony
Awards like the Oscars like the enemies
have catered so specifically to one
segments of the population now the easy
answer is they're all a bunch of leftist
and they hate the right that's true but
that doesn't explain why they've been
allowed to get away with it so the Tony
Awards do not get big ratings the Tony
Awards got
something like 6.3 million total viewers
by way of contrast Game four of the NBA
Finals which was down this year and drew
twice that drew twelve point nine
million viewers and few Americans have
actually seen the shows featured at the
Tony's basically Broadway attendance for
musicals has been effectively stagnant
since 2006 2007 nobody's seen any of
these plays so why is it that the Tonys
are so far out of the political
mainstream well the reason is because of
an element called renormalization so
renormalization is this weird thing
where a small group of people can impact
a large group of people so here's how it
works you have a family of four one of
the members of your family is a
vegetarian so instead of you having to
cook two separate meals you just cook a
vegetarian meal for everyone all right
so now all four people have to have a
vegetarian meal now that family goes to
a party there are four families there
and only one of the families is
vegetarian well the person is throwing
the party may think well you know I
really don't want to cook two meals so
I'm just gonna make the entire thing
vegetarian so one person who's
vegetarian can convert an entire group
of people into eating vegetarian at a
particular meal well the same thing
happens when it comes to Broadway
there are motivated niche groups who
only go to the theater if their
particular group is catered to and these
happen to be hardcore leftist groups
particularly and so those shows are what
tends to be produced because they figure
that everybody else is coming to
Broadway we'll see whatever it is that
is provided in the same way that the
meat-eater will eat the vegetarian meal
a bunch of people who don't care about
these news shows will go to see the news
shows cuz they're there for Broadway
anyway and that's how Broadway remains
liberal continues to make money it's
only exposed of course on the Tonys when
millions of people watch it when
millions of people see this liberalism
and this leftism put on full display in
front of the entire country and they
find it completely off-putting but
that's how the market actually allows
for Broadway and Hollywood remain so
left even while they alienate huge
swaths of the country okay so time for a
couple of things that I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like my kid has been I'm gonna talk a
little bit of Star Wars here because
there's a big news story about Kathleen
Kennedy so there's there's a lot of talk
about there Kathleen Kennedy who's the
head of Lucasfilm is going to step down
from the Star Wars franchise and she's
gonna step down as the head of Lucasfilm
and I am going to talk about that in
just second first I want to talk about
how much I like Star Wars because I like
Star Wars so much that my kids are
familiar with all the music their
favorite has been this rendition for a
little while my two-year-old son
particular
this may cause a channel war he loves
cello Wars okay cello Wars is that
there's this group of guys they're
called the piano guys and they did this
version of the Star Wars music and it's
just for two cellos and basically
there's a little bit of background music
I believe from a synthesizer or a piano
and it's pretty cool
[Music]
so it's pretty fun you can get all their
music on iTunes they have a lot of good
stuff so go check out the piano guys I
really enjoy a lot of their music this
thing has several million hits on on
YouTube for good reason it's pretty well
produced okay so I'm gonna talk about
Star Wars and Kathleen Kennedy and the
stuff I hate but first one more thing
that I like so this was pretty awesome
so I was walking on Saturday on Shabbat
I was walking around with my family and
we walked past a little league baseball
field and I had to stop and watch little
league baseball because literally
baseball is the best okay and as we were
walking by the Little League baseball
field the teams were going out there and
they were lining up and I didn't realize
this is what they do in little leagues I
played in Jewish little leagues so
usually we don't do any of this
particular stuff although I think that
we definitely should what they were
saying oh they line up both teams right
the opposing teams on the third base
line and the first base line and then
they had all the kids repeat this mantra
I trust in God I love my country and
will respect its laws I will play fair
and strive to win but win or lose I will
always do my best
that's all American stuff it's just
great unfortunately all those principles
are under attack from both some folks on
the left and some folks on the right
particularly when it comes to playing
fair and striving to win and to him your
best I think that those principles are
particularly under attack in today's
modern era unfortunately but these sort
of values do have an outcome and that
outcome is stuff like this so yesterday
this is just a beautiful video there was
a high school pitcher who was pitching
against I guess it's his it one of his
best friends since he was a kid and his
best friend played for another team from
another high school and this last pitch
wins him the high school his that the
winning team now gets to go to the state
championship in high school baseball and
what you're going to see in this video
is the is the pitcher strikeout the
batter and then his teammates rush to
celebrate on the mound and before they
can he goes and gives his best friend a
hug and comforts him about striking out
[Applause]
and then he finally goes and he
celebrates with his with his teammates
that's just great
that's just great I mean that's
sportsmanship and that's decency and
we're lacking a lot of that in in
today's modern politics okay time for a
couple of quick things that I hate okay
so the thing that I hate Michelle wolf
is awful okay she's awful she was awful
and she did the White House
Correspondents Dinner and she is awful
now so she has a show on Netflix which
nobody will ever watch we'll never know
the ratings because that's not how
Netflix actually makes its money they
make their money off subscriptions of
course so Michelle wolf did this routine
in this video where she plays a person
who is submitted to the op-ed page of
the New York Times and the op-ed editor
of the New York Times it turns out is an
actual clown but she's not gonna rip the
op-ed editor of the New York Times for
being too left no she's gonna rip the
op-ed editor of the New York Times from
being too right and she specifically
didn't go after Barry Weiss Barry Weiss
is the only semi conservative columnist
at the New York Times and it's Ross dude
hat and and David Brooks who's not
really very conservative at all and
Barry Weiss and Michelle wolf goes after
Barry Weiss because after all there are
certain opinions that are bad capital
ba-dee bad and they must not be allowed
to be given room on the on the pages of
the New York Times he was Michelle wolf
being a complete supposed to be
damnit enough Barry Weiss your opinion
suck they're bad opinions bad do you
even realize what you're doing people
look at your papers a trusted source for
informed opinions but instead you're
validating these back two points of view
maybe it's time you leave do not
validate the bad points of view people
michelle wolf is right Barry Weiss had
an opinion so has Barry Weiss ever
defended pizza gate of course not that's
asinine Barry Weiss's has written about
a wide variety of issues some of which
are not particularly Pro right-wing by
the way and there isn't a shovel saying
these are bad opinions bad understander
much a bad opinion bad opinion and you
don't deserve space in the newer times
now listen do I think they're legit bad
opinions yes I think that legitimate
racist opinions are bad for example I
think there are plenty of legitimately
bad opinions I think the opinion that
rape is a wonderful thing that's a
horrible opinion right there are plenty
of horrible opinions
Barry Weiss does not fall outside the
Overton Window but according to Michelle
wolf she does because according to show
up the only people who should be on the
pages of the op-ed of the New York Times
are people that Michelle wolf personally
agrees with now the great irony of this
is that Barry Weiss weren't a full
column defending Michelle wolf after the
White House Correspondents Dinner dinner
so apparently her bad opinions include
defending Michelle wolf pretty amazing
stuff okay now meanwhile other things
that I hate so I have to talk about this
briefly there's a whole upstate of
people who are now defending Kathleen
Kennedy Kathleen Kennedy is the head of
Lucasfilm and the reason that they are
defending Kathleen Kennedy is they say
that Kathleen Kennedy is doing a
wonderful job as the head of the Star
Wars universe she's not doing a bad job
pay no attention to the failures of so
low pay no attention to the last Jedi
pay no attention to any of that stuff
she is doing awesome and you know we do
it with how we know she's doing awesome
because Kathleen Kennedy is super woke
and the real reason that kept that Star
Wars is failing right now that Star Wars
is having some trouble the real reason
that Star Wars is is is feeling the pain
is because of these toxic fans now does
this sound familiar does it sound sort
of like what people said about Hillary
Clinton Hillary isn't failing because
Hillary sucks Hillary's failing because
everybody's deplorable that's exactly
what all these colonists are saying so
there's a guy named Mark Barnard and who
writes for The Hollywood Reporter he
says that all of these toxic fans quote
hate everything the new Star Wars stood
for hated what they saw as a social
justice warrior remix of the Star Wars
they grew up with and they hated trans
rose this would be the this cat this
actress what's her what's her first name
kaydee trami who plays Rose in the last
Star Wars movie which is a garbage part
most of all because they decide to
choose the avatar that all that was all
that was wrong with the franchise those
fans minority but allowed one found
there them and the very thing they used
to love those who chose this particular
vein of the dark side emboldened by the
faceless intoxication of the internet
went hard on Tran racist invective
misogyny rape and death threats all
hurled in her constantly unrelentingly
turn transforming what had been a
Cinderella story the last Jedi was trans
first major film into a modern-day
nightmare okay so if you think that this
group of reddit trolls who are like all
up on Tran that that is what is causing
Star Wars to fail you're an idiot
okay the real reason that Star Wars is
failing is not because of any of that
stuff because if it was because of that
stuff you would expected solo to do fine
the solo wasn't filled with as much sjw
nonsense the real reason that Star Wars
is failing is because Kathleen Kennedy
is terrible at her job okay the
Lucasfilm story group is that the reason
she's being defended again is because
she's super woke the New York Times had
a piece a few weeks ago talking about
Kathleen Kennedy's Lucasfilm story group
but they say quote they wanted to tell
beautiful stories fulfill the
expectations of loyal fans and create
meaningful female characters the Lucas
group story group is entirely female the
times gushes today the Lucasfilm story
group is a diverse outlier in Hollywood
five of its members are people of color
the team includes four women in seven
men a new unpublished analysis of Star
Wars film shows striking progress in the
representation of gender and race now I
don't care about any of that stuff I
care whether the movies are good but the
press cares about that stuff and that's
why they have to defend Kathleen Kennedy
from her bad creative decision-making
the reason that Star Wars has failed is
because they basically had two choices
on relaunching the Star Wars universe
one would be fast forward 50 years when
all the original characters are gone and
then you lose the nostalgia but at least
you've relaunched the universe or two
you recast the original characters and
you pick up a Return of the Jedi left
off but instead you chose door number
three which is bring back all the
original characters kill them off in the
stupidest possible ways and then try to
make backwards looking nostalgia films
about characters you've already
destroyed like solo I can't imagine why
that was a giant fail Kathleen Kennedy
should go but the media is gonna try and
save her because she's a woman and she's
a woke woman at the ads that's all that
matters okay quick explanation of a
federalist paper since we didn't do so
yesterday so Federalist number 32 we are
up to we can do this very quickly
Alexander Hamilton wrote Federalist 32
this is a continuation of his discussion
about the taxing power of the federal
government and what he says is that the
state and federal
we'll be able to have concurrent taxing
powers so there's a lot of worry at the
state level that if the federal
government can tax that that will
prevent the state from taxing and
Hamilton assures people that's not the
truth he says this exclusive delegation
or rather this alienation of state
sovereignty would only exist in three
cases where the Constitution in Express
terms grants an exclusive authority to
the Union were granted in one instance
in authority of the Union and another
prohibited the states from exercising
the like Authority and we're a granted
authority to the Union to which a
similar Authority in the States would be
absolutely and totally contradictory and
repugnant in other words unless the
Constitution explicitly rules out that a
state can do something the state can
still do something so this is his
argument and then he says states can tax
their citizens he says there is plainly
no expression in the granting clause
which makes that power exclusive in the
Union there's no independent clause or
sentence which prohibits the states from
exercising it in other words stop
worrying so much that the federal
government's going to tax everybody and
States won't be able to Hamilton was
right about this
both the feds and the states now to tax
people out of existence that's very
exciting stuff and that's because of the
growth of the federal government far
beyond what Hamilton ever could have
foreseen or approved okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest updates hopefully we'll have some
good news from the Trump administration
in terms of actual concrete steps that
the North Koreans will take to
denuclearize otherwise it was not a
great day but maybe it will be a good
day tomorrow we'll find out I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018